Bradley Cooper from the hangover plays
the smartest man alive he is a character
limit list is about a man who's offered
a drug which supposedly allows any human
to use 100% of his brain and after
taking that drug he suddenly just sees
the entire world completely differently
literally and figuratively
everything that at once did not make
sense to him suddenly is absolutely
clear he's able to see patterns in the
stock market he's able to finish his
book that he's been trying to figure out
how to write he's able to think his way
out of tough situations because he's
using 100% of his brain but of course
there are side effects to the drug not
only on himself but other people
suddenly want to know what in the world
is happening to him he gets involved
some dangerous people and some things
happen yeah I'll let you watch the movie
Bradley Cooper is very good in this film
I've seen him in a few things he's
always a very enjoyable actor I've never
really seen him give a kind of weighty
performance like this and he brings a
lot of depth to his character he's also
fun he's entertaining you know you can
tell that he's he's got the comedic side
but he's pretty good with the dramatic
stuff too in this film Robert DeNiro is
also and he plays a businessman that
Bradley Cooper gets involved with DeNiro
unfortunately wasn't given very much
material here to work with most of his
scenes are very young you know they're
just kind of passive there isn't a lot
of intense stuff for him to do it we all
know DeNiro can act up a huge storm and
he is just a fantastic actor and one of
my favorites and I was I was very
disappointed that he wasn't given as
much material he was in the last half of
the film for most of the movie it's just
that the material he was given wasn't
that great it was just I was kind of
disappointed with that he's a great
actor and he does well with what he's
given Abbie Cornish is a very good
actress who I've enjoyed him in previous
films she does a very good job as well
as kind of on-and-off-again girlfriend
that
Bradley Cooper has this is a good fellow
I enjoy limitless the good things about
this film are that has a very unique
visual style the opening credits
sequence it was a real eye-opener look
forward to that it has a lot of really
interesting visual tweaks they do with
the camera one of the cool things that I
enjoyed was that whenever he's on the
pill
everything is much brighter colors are
so explosive and when he's off the pill
it's a lot more dull all the
performances I enjoyed great job with
the acting the direction had some unique
different slants too and there are some
interesting sequences the direction
never became a distraction even though
there were a lot of unique things as he
did with the camera the problems I had
of this film where that it seemed very
disjointed something about the film
didn't seem like the scenes were
connecting it seemed like there were a
lot of really interesting scenes
throughout the film but that they didn't
necessarily form a cohesive whole
certain aspects of the film just seemed
like they were out of place also I don't
want to spoil anything but certain ways
that the film goes about finalizing the
story seemed rushed I'll put it that way
I don't want to spoil anything I hate
good to do that some some aspects of the
film seemed a little rushed it seemed
like certain things happen too fast but
for the most part this is a really
enjoyable movie it's good but not great
it has some disappointing things about
it mostly because it just feels a little
bit out of place it doesn't seem like
the whole film connects from beginning
to end it seems like a lot of little
segments of it are kind of like their
own little stories and then they don't
really necessarily all form that was
just kind of how I viewed it you may not
do it the same way and I was really
disappointed that dinero wasn't given
some more heavy material because man
that guy can act and you know if you
have robbed an arrow in your movie you
take advantage of that guy you take
advantage of Rob DeNiro
Bradley Cooper does a good job the
acting is good like I said inventive
visuals but I'm going to give it three
out of four it's a fun movie it's not as
good as The Lincoln Lawyer I suggest if
you're going to see a movie this week
and I have not seen Paul yet but so far
from what I've seen I would suggest
seeing Lincoln Lawyer over limitless
although they are both good and
enjoyable Lincoln Lawyer is definitely
better
limitless is about a man who is accepted
limitless it limitless is about my gosh
what is long limitless is about it
limitless is about a man who is accepted